good morning John I've spent this week
doing basically nothing but talking
about my new book which I have to be
honest love cuz I spent two years
writing it and not being able to talk
about it and I've had lots of things to
say and one thing that I keep getting to
talk about
he's idea in part because like there's a
lot of weird surprising things that
happen in the book and people like where
do you get your ideas in part because
the characters in the book talk about
ideas and where ideas come from and how
they come to ideas and this is an idea
that I'm fascinated with and have been
for a very long time as someone who kind
of has to come up with an idea for a
video every week it also as a person
because like where ideas come from is
really important because almost
everything is an idea like justice is an
idea and an evolving idea America is an
idea money is an idea borders are ideas
political parties and businesses are
ideas this is your doesn't have any
spoilers in it but there are two
characters that are having sort of a
different take on where ideas come from
one of them is struggling a lot with
feeling like he can't come up with any
actually original ideas and all he does
is like grab on to stuff from around him
and synthesize it into something
slightly new or just his own take on an
existing idea well the other character
has like a system that really works for
her and that's take a good robust strong
understanding of the problem that you're
trying to solve and a carefully selected
problem and second all of the tools that
you have access to and then you just
sort of like put them in your brain
bucket and shake them around and
something falls out and if that doesn't
work then you either have to change what
problem you're looking at or the scope
of the problem or you have to modify
your toolkit but here's the thing and
this isn't talked about in the book
those are actually the same thing that
first character what he's doing is not
identifying his core problem but he's
doing the second thing where he's trying
to modify his toolkit to see what falls
out and really his problem is that he's
supposed to have interesting stuff to
say like suddenly it is his job to have
good and interesting takes I had an
interviewer asked me yesterday if I
thought that there were actually ever
any new ideas or if we're in this like
weird sad were
where everything is just a slight tweak
to something else and I was like yeah
yes but there are new ideas every new
idea though is contingent upon all of
the old ideas there's a saying I think
that Newton said it if I if I thought of
anything original it was because I was
standing on the shoulders of giants
something like that I'm paraphrasing
I shouldn't paraphrase I should look at
it turns out it's older than Newton but
Newton did have his own take on it his
own tweak to this this is great if I
have seen further it is by standing on
the shoulders of giants but here's the
thing while that is very complimentary
we are not standing on the shoulders of
giants we are standing on the shoulders
of each other of normal-sized people
both of these books talk a lot about
music and that is not an accident
because music for me is the best example
in the clearest example of how every
creation is a collaboration with the
past
ideas are deeply dependent on our
toolkits and our toolkits didn't come
from nowhere and that's everything from
how we imagine the world the stories we
tell about ourselves in our society and
also the things that we actually know
about the universe and the skills and
talents that we've taken the time to
develop and so when people ask me where
ideas come from it's from there it's
from building on the work of billions of
other people over hundreds of thousands
of years and I cannot imagine thinking
that that makes this less amazing it
only makes it more amazing to me John
I'll see you on Tuesday